انفجار هائل يضيء السماء
ويحرق الأرض
لا يستطيع المحللون العسكريون تحديد
الأسلحة التي تستخدمها روسيا على وجه التحديد ، لكن
هذا جعل البعض مقتنعًا بأن موسكو
تصعد الصراع بطريقة مروعة
أعتقد أن هذا سلاح
حراري هو وقود متفجر في الهواء  إنه
سلاح مدمر للغاية اكتشف فريق CNN
قاذفات قنابل حرارية
بالقرب من الحدود الأوكرانية يطلقون
صواريخ ينتج عنها انفجارين
الأول يملأ الهواء بسرعة ببخار الوقود
والثاني يشعله مع
تأثير كارثي مما يجعل بعض الضحايا
يشعرون وكأن الهواء  يتم امتصاص
دانيال واسربلي من
رئتيهم وفقًا لمراجعة الدفاع الدولية الخاصة بجين ، لذا
دعنا نقول أن لديك أشخاصًا يختبئون ربما
في قبو أو خلف جدران
لن يكونوا محميين ضد شيء
كهذا لأن الهباء الجوي يمكن أن
يدخل القبو ويمكنهم التحرك حول الجدران
و  لقد اشتعلت النيران والجميع يموتون
موتًا مروّعًا للغاية ، وتشير مراقبة حقوق الإنسان
أيضًا إلى الحطام  كدليل
على إطلاق الروس للقنابل العنقودية
صواريخ تتشقق في الهواء
وتطلق العشرات من المتفجرات الصغيرة القوية
في جميع الاتجاهات إذا كنت
تقود سيارتك وذخيرة صغيرة
سقطت على سطح سيارتك أه
أنت وسيارتك ستفعل
ذلك  يقول محللون بعيدون إن العديد من
الضربات الروسية يبدو أنها اشتملت على
ذخائر مشتركة مثل صواريخ كروز المستهدفة ،
لكن المواقع المدنية تعرضت
للقصف إما عن طريق العمد أو بالصدفة ،
ويتوقع المسؤولون الأمريكيون أن عدد
المدنيين الذين قتلوا أو جرحوا أسوأ من أن
العواقب الإنسانية
ستزداد فقط في  قبل أيام مما
يقودنا إلى تلك القافلة الروسية المتوقفة
بالقرب من كييف المليئة بقطع المدفعية ،
وهي أداة مفضلة للجنرالات
الروس يعتقد المحللون أنه إذا تحركت هذه الأسلحة
مرة أخرى وتم وضعها في جميع أنحاء
المدينة ، فقد تمطر نيرانًا مدمرة على
الأهداف العسكرية والمدنية على حد سواء.
يمكن لهذه الأسلحة أن تقتل بسهولة وبشكل
عشوائي وقد تعهدت العديد من الدول
بعدم استخدامها أبدًا  تقول روسيا
إنها لم تستخدمها في أوكرانيا ،
لكن روسيا قالت الكثير
عما تفعله في أوكرانيا ، وقد أثبت الكثير منها
عدم صحة
توم فورمان سي إن إن
واشنطن
برج التلفزيون هذا هنا على بعد ثلاثة
أميال فقط من وسط المدينة التي تحدثنا عنها
مع الحراس الذين كانوا هنا بالأمس قالوا
إن هذا الهجوم من الروس
جاء دون سابق إنذار ، ويعتقدون أنه
كان هناك حوالي أربعة صواريخ أصابت جميع
أنحاء هذه المنطقة بما في ذلك
التأثير المباشر على البرج نفسه ، ولا يزال بإمكانك
رؤية الضرر بشكل كبير بالطبع.
منطقة سوداء حول منتصفها
بالإضافة إلى النوافذ
التي تم تحطيمها تمامًا ولكن من الواضح أنه كان
هناك عدد من الصواريخ التي سقطت في
كل مكان هنا الكثير والكثير من
الأضرار الجانبية الآن نعلم من
السلطات الأوكرانية أن حوالي خمسة
أشخاص قتلوا
لك  لا يزال بإمكاننا رؤية بعض الدم
على الرصيف الآن بالطبع نحن
على الجانب الآخر من الشارع من أه هذا البرج ولكن
فقط ألق نظرة على هذا أه على هذا
المبنى و  يقول
إنه الآن مدمر تمامًا هنا في
الطابق الأرضي أه من الواضح أن هذه صالة ألعاب رياضية ،
يمكنك رؤية جميع معدات الصالة الرياضية ،
دراجات ثابتة ، مدرب بيضاوي الشكل ،
لا يزال
هناك حريق يشتعل هناك الكثير من الدخان آه
يخرج
من هذا المبنى
الآن  هذه منطقة تسمى بابين
وهي المكان الذي وقعت فيه إحدى أسوأ
مذابح اليهود في الحرب العالمية الثانية ، حيث
قُتل حوالي 30000 شخص
على مدار يومين ، لذا فهي
منطقة ذات رمزية للغاية وهنا لديك
هجوم من قبل رجل فلاديمير بوتين  من
يدعي أنه يحاول نزع النظرة عن
أوكرانيا أه على
أرض مجوفة بشكل أساسي هذا على
لسان وزير الخارجية توني بلينكن أه
هجوم مروّع
أه الرئيس زيلينسكي يقول أيضًا
أن هذا دليل على أن التاريخ
يعيد نفسه كما سمعنا.
مرارًا وتكرارًا من الروس
بأنهم لا يستهدفون
البنية التحتية المدنية ، سمعنا هذا الادعاء مرة أخرى
اليوم
ولكن من الواضح أنهم يضربون
البنية التحتية المدنية ويقتلون بشكل واضح
نانوغرام عدد متزايد
من الأوكرانيين